i feel a sense of
um
self at the moment with myself
professionally where i am the work that
i'm doing the work that i'm creating and
that's my big baby you know
my my career has been my greatest rock
in my whole life well now priyanka
chopra and husband nick jonas are
welcoming a real baby into their lives
it's a special thing that's right nick
and pre are officially new parents my
life is very good right now very excited
the couple shared the happy news in a
joint statement on instagram quote we
are overjoyed to confirm that we have
welcomed a baby via surrogate we
respectfully ask for privacy during this
special time as we focus on our family
thank you so much i have a lot of faith
in who my husband is and i know i have a
lot of faith in
the rock that he is for our family the
pair started dating in 2016 and have
been married since 2018. i think we
settled into
our roles as husband and wife like
fairly quickly communication having fun
with each other
i think that's the most important the
key is to be able to enjoy each other's
company and just have a great time
then it just it doesn't feel like work
both have said many times that they hope
to have kids but a source previously
told et that they weren't putting any
pressure on themselves um babies as many
as god would give us a year later in
2020 things got more serious with the
source telling e.t that nick and
priyanka have been talking about having
children in their near future the couple
has always wanted kids plus their kid
would be in good company brother kevin
jonas has two daughters valentina and
alina and brother joe jonas has one
daughter willa any insights into
fatherhood any lessons learned in your
year plus yeah
naps are nice
all around meanwhile bianca has been
booked and busy there's so many things
while promoting her film matrix
resurrections e.t learned all about how
she and nick plan to slow down during
the holidays our big tradition is trying
to spend christmas
together because we're always doing so
many things apart but
just being home with the family that's
all and for the power couple being
together is what matters most we both
really really respect our
our work ethic and we both know how
important our work is to each other that
it's really important i mean i think for
anyone in any relationship it's really
important to find a partner
that can support your individual
ambition or your individual dreams you
know outside of them
and and let you do that thing and i feel
like that's the healthiest relationship
[Music]